Зниження тарифів, закінчення війни на Донбасі та подолання бідності -
цього найбільше чакають виборці
від нового президента України Володимира Зеленського.
Однак глава держави може стати заручником завищених очікувань.
Це - уривок із передвиборчих відеоблогів Володимира Зеленського.
У ньому експерти констатували
факт високих комунальних платежів українців
порівняно з зарплатами і припустили,
що за місяць можна буде їх зменшити.
Блог із лютого до червня вже подивилися
понад 1,5 мільйона разів.
Після обрання Зеленського президентом
представник глави держави в уряді Андрій Герус наголосив,
що його шеф напряму ніде не обіцяв зниження тарифів. Так і є.
Насправді президент України не має повноважень
видавати укази про зниження тарифів,
однак глава держави може накласти вето
на постанови Кабінету міністрів, якщо в них будуть
ознаки порушення прав та свобод громадян.
Щоби з'ясувати, чи були такі порушення,
президент має звернутися до Констутиційного суду,
який і має ухвалити остаточне рішення відносно постанови уряду.
Кадрові зміни сталися:
другий президент Леонід Кучма знову представляє Україну
у Тристоронній контактній групі в Мінську.
Це поки єдина конкретика від нового президента.
Мінські угоди передбачають реалізацію
конституційної реформи щодо надання
окремим регіонам Донецької та Луганської областей особливого статусу.
У цій схемі дій немає Росії, яка не вважає себе стороною конфлікту
і називає свою агресію внутрішньоукраїнською проблемою.
Зеленський хоче прямого діалогу з РФ.
Виборці Зеленського прагнуть, щоб президент закінчив війну.
Однак Росія поки не готова ані до перемовин,
ні до співпраці з проєвропейською та прозахідною Україною.
Тож для початку будь-яких переговорів Кремль вимагатиме поступок,
які можуть спричинити протести в українському суспільстві.
І як би Зеленський не хотів закінчити війну на Донбасі, це залежатиме від Путіна.
"Необхідно запровадити економічний паспорт українця.
Кожна дитина матиме право
накопичувати на своєму рахунку
частину від реалізації державою природніх благ (надра, землі тощо).
Після досягнення повноліття дитина отримає
ці накопичення як власний стартовий капітал", –
йдеться у програмі Володимира Зеленського.
Поки не пролунало конкретних механізмів
здійснення цього пункту програми.
Члени команди Зеленського заявили, що
вони сповідують лібертаріанську ідеологію, яка
передбачає свободу для бізнесу, що має стати локомотивом економіки.
Українська економіка потребує структурних реформ
і президент тут може допомогти своєю політичною волею,
а решта вже залежатиме від команди урядовців
у економічному секторі і прийняття Верховною Радою необхідних законів,
зокрема як оголошений Зеленським податок на виведений капітал.
Схоже на те, що Володимир Зеленський,
як і всі без винятку попередні президенти в Україні,
став заручником завищених очікувань своїх виборців.
Однак і питання тарифів, і встановлення миру,
і подолання бідності напряму не залежать лише від президента.
Медовий місяць із виборцями ще триває, однак
вже проявляються перші ознаки майбутнього розчарування.